Hi
I'm Anna Akana
And I have six cats
If I could I'd have all the cats
How many cats is too many cats?
There's no such number
And I have six cats
I wish I had infinity cats
You should adopt a couple of cats
I have six cats
This is Lily
she's my oldest kitty
This is Abby
she's a fat tabby
This is Jimmy
he's the grumpy kitty
This is Congress
he's dumb
and he doesn't do anything
And I have six cats
If I could I'd have all the cats
How many cats is too many cats?
There's no such number
And I have six cats
I wish I had infinity cats
You should adopt a couple of cats
I have six cats
This is Beetle
he was a dumpster baby
We chopped off his balls
but he's still crazy
This is Ghost
and she growls
On cue
(Actual Ghost the cat noises)
She's either a Really Good 4
or Really Bad 2
And I have six cats
If I could I'd have all the cats
How many cats is too many cats?
There's no such number
And I have six cats
I wish I had infinity cats
You should adopt a couple of cats
I have six cats